[Musik]
artikel 5 jeder hat das recht seine
meinung in wort schrift und bild frei zu
äußern
so steht es im grundgesetz doch es gibt
streit darf wirklich jeder alles sagen
unabhängig von herkunft geschlecht und
hautfarbe ist ein alter weiser mann
da war es gar nicht wovon er redet er
kennt unsere betroffenheit nicht das
weiß sein ist ja nicht das neutrale
außen von rassismus sondern der kern von
rassismus
[Musik]
ein weißer professor will über
kolonialismus reden helmut bley ein
anerkannter experte für die geschichte
des kolonialismus er hat an hochschulen
in deutschland den usa und afrika
gelehrt geplant war ein vortrag in
hannover ich wollte mal von innen von
der afrikanischen perspektive wie sind
die eigentlich in den kommunismus
hineingegangen und auch wieder
rausgegangen ausgehen sollte diskutieren
mit einer antirassistischen initiative
ihr name i dir so präsentiert sie sich
im netz sind für die also was ist uns
kritisch ist drin in jeglichen
institutionen in jeglichen ausbildungen
aber vor allen dingen der lehre
nach einem vorgespräch kommt es zum
eklat der erste satz der von der
sprecherin der idee ihrer gesagt war ihm
ein alter weiser mann kann grundsätzlich
über afrikanische dinge denken und
urteilen
daraufhin habe ich dann ein bisschen
perplex reagiert damit würden sie ja die
gesamte wissenschaftlichen möglichkeiten
der gesellschaftswissenschaften der
ethnologie in frage stellen die im
rathaus von hannover geplante diskussion
lehnte dieser ab in den sozialen medien
macht die antirassistische initiative
dem historiker vorwürfe zitat
zudem mangelte es beim
aufeinandertreffen an einem
wertschätzenden umgang für eine
diskussion auf augenhöhe
im netz gibt es zuspruch
was qualifiziert einen europäer darüber
zu referieren was afrikaner denken wenn
ich wissen will wie afrikaner über die
kolonialzeit denken frage ich ein
afrikaner aber hier geht es darum dass
ein weißer darüber sprechen wollte was
afrikaner denken
ein interview mit frontal21 lehnt ihrer
dazu ab die stadt hannover reagiert auf
den streit und lädt professor blei aus
erklärungsversuche passiert ist dass die
eigentlich mit dem anderen reden wollten
das somit für uns das problem bestand
dass wir keine diskussionsveranstaltung
wie wir sie geplant hatten mehr
durchführen konnten und das wir dann die
veranstaltung abgesagt haben natascha
kelly ist promovierte soziologin und
aktivisten dass ein weißer
wissenschaftler wie professor blei über
die unterdrückung von schwarzen spreche
ist für sie ein typischer fall von
strukturellen rassismus
er kann über kolonialismus aus einer
weißen perspektive sprechen
das ist eine andere geschichte die
verwoben ist mit kolonialismus aus einer
schwarzen perspektive dass die
unterdrückung also in form von apps
islamische gewalt die zeigt sich wenn er
glaubt er kann für uns sprechen nein
kann er nicht das ist ja das problem
kelly beklagt es gebe keine
gleichberechtigung für schwarze menschen
an deutschen hochschulen
warum muss überhaupt ein weißer mann die
perspektive eines schwarzen person
übernehmen weil wir keinen zugang haben
dazu das ist das strukturell das ganze
es gibt ja nicht um ihn als einzelne
person
es geht um das system um das machtsystem
was dahinter ist also wenn wir nur
betroffene ermächtigen über ihre
gesellschaft nachts nachzudenken etwa
noch betroffene die zwei oder drei
generationen nach dem ereignis selber
leben also gar nicht dabei waren dann
gefährdet das die wissenschaftsfreiheit
wer darf reden herbst 2009 10 studenten
hindern professor bernd lucke daran an
der universität hamburg eine vorlesung
zu halten
der frühere ard vorsitzende lücke habe
kein rederecht wissenschaftler
widersprechen
natürlich darf bernd lucke sprechen es
ist zwar legitim zu protestieren
allerdings ist es ja kein zeichen von
charakterliche reife wenn man versucht
das gegenüber nieder zu brüllen
natürlich kann man sagen herr lucke
wieso haben sie die afg mit gegründet
was haben sie sich dabei gedacht fühlen
sich verantwortlich für das was jetzt
passiert ist zum beispiel und geht dann
in dialog mit ihm das ist das was
universität ausmacht doktor sandra
costner hat mit 70 hochschullehrern das
netzwerk wissenschaftsfreiheit gegründet
auslöser war ein vortrag von hamed
abdel-samad der politologe ist einer der
schärfsten kritiker des radikalen islam
in deutschland
und er kam an einer stelle auch auf das
kopftuch zu sprechen
der erste satz war wenn er erwachsene
frau freiwild das kopftuch trägt dann
muss man das natürlich akzeptieren
sie soll es sich aber dessen immer
gewahr sein dass sie damit auch das
patriarchat auf der schulter trägt und
er fände es aus gründen der staatlichen
neutralität bei lehrerin nicht
akzeptabel
daraufhin ist eine kopftuchtragende
studentin die ich nicht kannte
aufgestanden hat unter protest den raum
verlassen die studenten zeigte
abdel-samad an wegen volksverhetzung
sie hat mehrfach betont der grund für
diese strafanzeige war dass sie damit
sicherstellen wollte dass in zukunft
niemand mehr und die hochschule
eingeladen wird der das kopftuch
kritisiert weil sie hätte ein recht auf
ein diskriminierungsfrei studium und das
war also ein ganz klares ziel von ihr
die hochschule als schutzraum vor
meinungen zu etablieren und nicht das
was die hochschule einig sein sollte
nämlich ein schutzraum von meinungen die
anzeige blieb folgenlos doch der streit
um sprechverbote hat längst die politik
erreicht im februar debattiert die spd
online über identität und minderheiten
und was das für sozialdemokratische
politik bedeutet stadtpolitik streit um
begriffe ich bin eingeladen worden und
jetzt dreimal gemischt geändert worden
ich bin kein herr und ich bin auch nicht
schauspieler oder regisseur
ich bin schauspieler innen und
regisseurin ich bin nicht binär ich bin
eine geoutete lesbische nicht binäre
person wolfgang thierse macht das ratlos
wir können nicht mehr frei und ungehemmt
sprechen ohne dass die reaktion heftig
ist dass wir beschimpft werden dass wir
verdächtigt werden
reaktionäre zu sein nicht nur
konservative seine reaktionäre rassisten
homophob zu sein tier sogar ddr
bürgerrechtler war bundestagspräsident
und ist seit jahrzehnten spd mitglied im
märz schreibt er im zeit magazin
ich bin mittlerweile zum symbol geworden
für viele normale menschen die unsicher
sind was sie noch sagen dürfen und wie
sie es sagen dürfen
er beklagt sprechverbote die sogenannte
cancel culture und erntet ein shitstorm
die sogenannte normalität ist die
eigentliche cancelte normalität ist die
cancel culture des alten weißen mannes
und nein wolfgang alter weißer mann ist
kein rassismus es ist eine
zustandsbeschreibung der westlichen
machtverhältnisse die über alles und
alle entscheidend wenn mir einer sagt
und weil ich weiß bin weil ich in europa
und in deutschland lebe bin ich schon
schuldig was soll ich damit tue ich kann
nicht aus mir selber aussteigen wenn
gesagt wird
rassismus ist in die dna unserer
gesellschaft eingetragen dann gilt
dasselbe
ich kann nicht aus meiner dna aussteigen
und deswegen sage ich es gibt ein gibt
vorwürfe von so fundamentaler
allgemeinheit die hilflos machen
tatsächlich nimmt der kampf um die
identität mittlerweile bizarre züge an
emilia von sänger hat in berlin einen
buchladen eröffnet schwerpunkt queer
feministische literatur doch weil ihr
großvater ein ns offizier war wird sie
angefeindet sie habe mit nazi geld den
laden finanziert werfen ihr aktivisten
vor wie ihr die menschen mit migrations
folgen müssen die einst immer wieder
daran erinnern dass sie die menschen
mitnehmen hintergrund sind weil sie es
entscheidet immer wieder vergessen was
dachtest du denn woher dein ganzes geld
kommt die familie blickt auf eine
250-jährige soldaten tradition zurück da
muss der sehr viel blut mit involviert
sein und geld das von damals stand es um
eine ist natürlich kein geld dass er
unschuldig ist
meron mendl ist direktor der
bildungsstätte anne frank er hält solche
vorwürfe gegen die buchhändlerin und ihr
geerbtes geld für maßlos übertrieben
ich finde das kann man überhaupt nicht
verlangen weil das geld der ober
sozusagen in familien über generationen
gehört da ist es nicht mal kurz das ist
einfach eine eine vorstellung die sowas
von realitätsfernen ist von daher würde
ich das auf keinen fall auf diese
persönliche ebene an einzelpersonen das
fest festmachen
doch von solchen argumenten lassen sich
die kritik am ostarrichi land sind gem
barataria nicht beeindrucken
man kann ja nicht die taten der
urgroßeltern erben
aber man kann die verantwortung
natürlich erben und da auch nicht
familiär sondern gesellschaftlich auch
vor allem aber was man erben kann
familie ist eigentlich das ist was ganz
sehr konkret dass es gibt kaum denn es
gibt gab mir ein es sei schlimmeres kann
die nazis genau so wie es heute
rassismus gibt aber keine tasten und ich
glaube hier haben wir ein echt ein
schwerwiegendes problem
sie fordern mehr achtsamkeit gegenüber
herkunft sexueller orientierung und
identität so genannte bündnis doch der
fall mit der buchhändlerin geht vielen
zu weit es folgt polemik auf instagram
diskutiert das vocal dorf wie deutsche
mit ns familiengeschichte umgehen
offenbarungseid von boko haram und ihren
bunten instagram richtern die nun eine
kriminalistische buchhandlung
vorzuführen versuchten es wird immer
bescheuerter mir geht das noch nicht
weit genug schließlich sind wir alle
menschen mit neandertaler hintergrund
emilia von sänger lehnt ein interview
mit frontal21 ab und ihrer kritiker
fühlen sich verletzt
es war unfair also es fühlt sich nicht
mehr so an es war einfach unfair und der
inhalt war gar nicht mehr
das thema sondern wir als person
personen und welche rolle wir einen
dieser debatte der streit um die
identitätspolitik spaltet die linke
davon ist sahra wagenknecht
spitzenpolitikerin der linken überzeugt
die klassische mittelschicht die
arbeiterschaft geringverdiener und all
diese leute beteiligen sich ja gar nicht
an solchen debatten
also das sind ja in der regel
privilegierte die solche diskussionen
führen und sich dann teilweise als opfer
inszenieren obwohl es ihnen eigentlich
gut geht und sie auch nicht wirklich ein
opfer sind wagenknecht hat ein buch
geschrieben darin heißt es die
identitätspolitik läuft darauf hinaus
das augenmerk auf immer kleinere und
immer skurrilere minderheiten zu richten
die ihre identität jeweils in
irgendeiner marotte finden durch die sie
sich von der mehrheitsgesellschaft
unterscheiden und aus der sie den
anspruch ableiten ein opfer zu sein geht
das nicht zu weit herkunft als
skurrilität transgender als marotte die
antwort im netz vernichtend wagenknecht
ist sollte ideologisch inzwischen
komplett auf linie von saf de bzw
identitaire bewegung bisschen
minderheiten bashing hier bisschen trans
feindlichkeit da
sorry aber das heute war mehr als nur
ein unfall was wagenknecht über gender
und schutzsuchende und antirassismus
sagt ist unerträglich
der spalt zwischen deutsch und
migrantinnen es spaltet die eigene
partei ist spaltet die wählerinnen
schaffen und das ist im wahljahr finde
ich ein großes problem weil parteien die
streiten die werden nicht gewählt von
der bevölkerung movassat und weitere
linke forderten dass sahra wagenknecht
ihre kandidatur für den bundestag zurück
zieht
die realität ist auch dass sich niemand
aus sucht opfer zu sein natürlich wäre
jeder mensch mit einer anderen hautfarbe
froh wenn er nicht angst haben müsste
nachts auf die straße zu gehen wenn er
nicht angst haben müsste vor
diskriminierung wenn er nicht die sorge
haben ist das wenn er eine bewerbung
schreibt er in seinem namen aussortiert
wird
insofern ist das was sarah wagenknecht
macht eine täter opfer umkehr über
rassismus muss man da reden wo es ihn
wirklich gibt und den muss man bekämpfen
aber nicht indem man sprach verbote
ausspricht oder nicht indem man die
sprache einfacher leute reglementiert
ist absurd sahra wagenknecht wird trotz
des streits zur bundestags
spitzenkandidaten der linken in
nordrhein westfalen gewählt
auch in der spd tobt ein kampf um
wolfgang thierse gehört der alte weiße
mann noch dazu spd-chefin esken und
vorstandsmitglied kühnert schrieben zum
streit um die identitätspolitik das
beschämt uns zutiefst
sie nennen es ein rückwärtsgewandtes
bild der spd und meinen auch wolfgang
thierse das wort normal davon
offensichtlich nicht mehr verwenden aber
so zu seinem sinne des deutschen wortes
normal nämlich gewöhnlich
durchschnittlich üblich nicht extrem was
normal ist und was nicht dazu will sich
die spd nicht äußern
normal dem begriff reklamiert jetzt der
politische gegner für sich die afd
was ist das eigentlich heute normal ist
alle heimat sind sichere grenzen sind
saubere straßen deutschland
aber normal wäre fd das feld überlässt
im streit um identität und politik
begehe einen großen politischen fehler
war thierse rechte intensität politik
für zu hass und gewalt insofern sie
vorstellungen von ethnischer homogenität
vertritt und damit alle möglichen
anderen ausgrenzt und das muss man
entschieden ablehnen